um talk about nf nfts again let's
still let's get into a little i'm gonna
get [ __ ] because
i already i already did some light some
weak roasting
of garyvee today in my youtube video and
i was already getting [ __ ] so if we i
was trying to point out
that getting [ __ ] from who just the
comments were like
you you cody just do the whole podcast
about nfts i'm like yeah but dude we
weren't there being like
i'm waiting for the flexification
of nfts
[Laughter]
i'm looking for the fleximization
of enemies like we weren't doing that we
were talking about like
like tech dudes tech dude's ability to
like jump on a wave
and like vocalize their
uh support in it is like unfucking
believable they're like the
like epitome of bandwagon people because
it's like
they were on this two years ago when
[ __ ] was first popping when
people were like oh we really think this
is the future like people that are
actually
invested in this and starting companies
and all that stuff yeah like now that
it's mainstream
all these guys are like the most vocal
people ever when it comes to this like
every tweet now from garyvee is about
nfts and his belief that it's the future
and blah blah blah and it's like
yeah that's such you're not paving the
way you're just like
no that's such a sharper way of putting
it and
like it's in my video to be fair like i
was on [ __ ] three percent battery
like my brain was
next to off so i just couldn't form a
good thought but the thing i was trying
to say was like
these dudes just they look at like i
swear their assistants come up to them
with a list and they're like all right
you have five podcast appearances this
week this is all the hot stuff
you need to make sure you hit all these
beats and then they just get on there
and they're like
non-fungible tokens i think it's um i
think it's going to replace dialysis
i mean i think it's just absolutely the
future
you say dialysis yeah or is that not
right what is it again
i'm not really oh it's money it's fun
fun money money right right or art is
art
right and art i'm a big fan of art as
you know like i believe art
is you know the uh uh i mean it's like
the main voice cultural voice you know
i think nfts will be the future of money
and art
and sex is sex on there too
it is it is it who's too mad
it's something about his titties it's
too mad a woman it's a
it's a boy it's a young boy got it got
it
i think two mads titties this looks like
will be the future of art in this
country
that's what garyvee and some this other
[ __ ] were talking about they were
like
uh garyvee said i'm waiting for the
flexa
i can't even remember the word he said
he's like
it was like fl he said flexification
because he's like we love to flex i'm
waiting for the flexication
flick whatever the [ __ ] of nfts like
basically saying when you can show it
off
it's like okay like when i'm like
that's vr dude yeah that exists
you [ __ ] dummy and i cut this out but
he goes on this whole rant about like
fractional ownership i'm like dude
there's an app called rally that's been
around
for i think four or five years that's
been doing fractional ownership it
started with
antique cars and they do other [ __ ] like
did they just don't
fractional ownership of nfts no no of
of cars like just items because
basically he was saying nfts offer a way
for fractional ownership and that's
going to pave the way for collectibles
and other things like
he was all about but in what sense like
multiple people will own the same
collectible
yeah yeah yeah yeah and they'll just own
a piece of it
right like his the people who work on
his podcast are
gunning for you know ownership of like a
michael jordan rookie card or something
um but that just i was just like [ __ ]
you that's been around for so long
like yeah every time time shares
i mean even that but i mean like
specifically with what he's talking
about
like there have been applications before
that it's not like
it's not because nft exists that this is
going to be a thing
gotcha you get what i'm saying like yeah
yeah like if you're interested in those
things you don't need to go through nft
to have
for example fractional ownership of like
an antique vehicle
you know that's been around um
uh that's just so [ __ ] yeah but yeah
it's your point like
these dudes just they
they're looking for content i feel out
of all this and
it's just annoying like well it's like
it's
it's like they can capitalize off of the
tube though because like they're
so vocal and they have such a big
following that they can boost
they can like oh yeah boost the trend
even higher than it already is and they
they make money
off vic because they're invested in
companies that are nft companies or
whatever
but um and then when it goes away
they're like
not it's just funny i don't know like
this the amount of nft
talk i guess on like clubhouse and
twitter is [ __ ]
insane yeah and it is like a really cool
technology i agree but it's like
it's a little bit egregious do you see
that you see an interesting thing
uh is that michael bury you know like
the
the dude that uh you know the big short
that guy
the main guy uh yeah yeah yeah the first
guy to short the housing market
yep and also the like the dude that
shorted gamestop the first time
too yeah or like he was one that kind of
started that whole movement as well
he has been like basically
tweeting about how this is a bubble and
like the market is showing
crazy signs that it's a bubble and he
like deleted his all of his tweets on
his account this week
and basically said you know you know my
stance like i'm going offline
and just disappeared wow
that's cold i think i think there has to
be something
yeah i think there has to be something
weird about this just in that um
oh there was just some [ __ ] there's
like a twitter moment today you know oh
this
this person spent 150k on nba top shop
but now it's worth 20 million i'm like
something's wrong here i think it's what
i'm saying it's not it's
it's not even that like i i don't want i
don't know this person like if they made
20 million good for them like
i just the amount of people who have
these stories like
this person made 11 million this person
made 20. this person made one this art
is
it's like just there's not that much
money out like how
can all of this [ __ ] be worth like
literally a bajillion dollars when you
add it all up like that's not possible
yeah i mean like in one sense there's
and it totally is in line with
what we're talking about because on one
sense there's people like garyvee
we follow him on twitter and he's like
constantly spouting the benefits
and all these crazy technologies that's
gonna come from nft and you're like holy
[ __ ] this is the best thing ever
and then you realize that a picture of
two mads titties
sold for how much luke what is the most
it's like a couple g's man i think you
made like five g's total
five g's on two pictures of his boobs
yeah
and it's like that's really cool but
it's also definitely a sign
that's something it's not right
i'm not saying his titties aren't worth
5k each
current bid price is 5k each that's
i mean he's got some nice boobs yeah but
but you know i don't know i don't know
if this is a good sign for the economy
that's all i'm saying
oh my dude dude no the current price
for the left diddy is nine thousand
dollars
dude people are going to they're just
burning their biden bucks on this [ __ ]
yeah that's gonna be the saddest part
this stimulus is gonna go into the
economy
and [ __ ] are going to spend
that [ __ ] on nft
art and get boned
i mean i don't know famous last words we
i thought bitcoin would come back but
that [ __ ] went
right back to 56 g's but you know who
knows yes but that could that could pop
a little bit too who knows
i believe i like crypto i'm not like
anti-crypto
at all i believe in it but i'm just
saying there's a lot of
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on right now
that's like just totally illogical
and that doesn't mean i don't believe in
the technology at all
no i'm so technology so bullish on it
but i just think that
the the amount of money being spent and
me too i spent
you know it's been what was it 1800
bucks on a
[ __ ] nft piece of art that said is a
chain that said these nuts on it
and i bought it because like i have a
bunch of ethereum i might as well it's
just like
it idiotic why would i do that you know
[Music]
yeah i want to get in on it if this is
actually going to be something i want to
maybe this piece is going to be worth 2
million one day who knows
yeah yeah i mean it's uh um
crypto is awesome but it just you just
wonder where it all
sort of ends up because with the whole
like environmental aspect
you know it would it would be nothing
for i mean who knows man
if the the you know tinfoil hat time
with the powers that be we're like yeah
no we can't have that
shut those farms down and that's just
like who's doing
you know whatever you know so basically
nvidia needs to hurry up and manufacture
graphics cards so we can all start to
run
the blockchain you know globally in an
efficient way
and to preserve the value of our nft art
and make sure that whoever spends 10 gs
on
two man's left titty that their
investment is honored and protected yes
yes i was like
i was we're going all with all this this
is really all just like one big
campaign for nvidia to hurry it up
so that whoever owns two mads titty can
display that with pride yeah and that'll
never be taken away from him
yeah because they deserve to own that
and and
yeah have it yeah
anyway i was just gonna say i saw a
garyvee clip about
he was like yeah but what you're not
thinking about with nft art
is what about when you have a digital
picture frame
and you're able to display your nft art
and i was like i heard that and i was
like oh yeah
good point i guess i always thought
about it as an image on a screen but now
i guess you could and i was like wait
we've had that for [ __ ] 10 years
like for like the shitty frame that your
mom or your
parents had in the in the kitchen janky
slight like powerpoint through pictures
of your family
dog your apple tv does that [ __ ] put it
in your [ __ ] photos
run your icloud through that [ __ ] no
one cares no
he's so like weirdly convincing like
when he's talking that i was like oh
yeah
art frame would be cool for this piece
of art that i just bought and i was like
well i could just
also just do that i could just download
the picture from anywhere and then just
display it
like yeah it's only gonna be cool
when we have the second life
fully figured out when everybody's apple
ar
slash vr ray-bans work perfectly
and we can hook into the amazon burger
tube
you know what i mean protein tube i
should say so you can strap on your
amazon backpack and have it pumping the
amazon
just just mystery meat and sludge
you can put on your apple ar glasses and
switch to vr
and your friends visit you virtually and
you're like look at my sick nft art
and you know then they're like wow i
can't believe we survived the nuclear
fallout
and now we can all you know visit each
other
after you know 72 strains of coronavirus
develop
yeah and that's what it would take
you can say look at my sick nft art of
the burger king
tweet on national women's day i own them
as you're slurping burger king
through your straw you say i own this
women belong tokenized misogyny man
tokenized misogyny you just don't you
don't see it like this anymore
that's what it's gonna be that's what's
gonna be the
the museum of online misogyny
and it's just gonna be a vr museum
with all just you know britney
moments justin timberlake moments in
that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the lake the tuba museum and then you
know in the back the centerpiece of it
is [ __ ] burger king
uk women belong in the kitchen
you